bienvenidos de nuevo solo estoy tratando
de mostrarles muchos ejemplos posibles
de resolver ecuaciones diferenciales
exactas uno intentando primero averiguar
si son exactas y entonces si ya lo sabes
puedes encontrar la aps y que nos
resuelve el problema verdad entonces en
el siguiente ejemplo o más bien el que
teníamos anteriormente teníamos 3x
cuadrada menos 2x y todo más más me
faltó más 2 x de equis y ahora sumamos
66 de cuadrada - x cuadrada más 3 y todo
esto por de ye igual a cero así que el
camino que estaba escrito no es
exactamente lo que queremos verdad así
que no no tenemos de la forma algo de la
forma m
fx demás en el x
por equis o ye prima igual a cero
entonces pero estamos muy cerca
realmente como podríamos obtener esta
ecuación diferencial pues simplemente
derivando perdón dividiendo entre de x
ambos lados de la ecuación entonces nos
queda 3x cuadrada menos 2 x + 2
ok y pues se cancela la de x y luego 6 y
cuadrada menos equis cuadrada más 3 por
de y / de x y esto es igual a cero ok
entonces ya lo tenemos hemos escrito
esto en la forma que que nos da o que
nos nos da la intuición de si es una
ecuación diferencial exacta o no
entonces vamos a revisar esto cuál es la
derivada parcial de m respecto de eso
perdón que pinte de rosa era una más
entonces cuál es la derivada parcial de
m respecto de ye pues esto es menos 2
x verdad porque lo demás es constante y
la derivada parcial de en el respecto de
x pues simplemente será menos dos hechos
ok ahí lo tienen la derivada de m
respecto de y es igual a la derivada de
n respecto de x verdad y como ya hemos
visto en otros vídeos anteriores estamos
en el caso de una ecuación diferencial
exacta ahora tendremos que encontrar
nuestra función sí que depende de xy de
jeff sabemos que la derivada parcial de
epsy respecto de x es m que es el 3 x
cuadrada menos 2 x + 2 ok entonces
tomaremos la primitiva o la integral
respecto de x en ambos lados y que
tenemos que si es igual a x al cubo - x
cuadrada y ok porque ya es una constante
más 2x y una función que depende de de
bail y agregamos una función que depende
de porque como ya hemos visto en vídeos
anteriores
derivamos esta expresión respecto de x
obtenemos la línea de arriba y entonces
pues cualquier derivada de una función
que depende de iu respecto de x pues
simplemente se anula verdad entonces
cómo le hacemos ahora vamos a tomar la
derivada parcial de epsy respecto de
ella y eso debe ser igual a nuestra
función n de acá arriba así que esto
será simplemente - x cuadrada ok es más
la derivada de h respecto de ella y esto
debe ser igual
esta función que subrayamos de amarillo
así que va a ser igual a 6 cuadrada - x
cuadrada + 3 ok entonces quitamos la
equis cuadrada de ambos lados y lo que
obtenemos es que la derivada de h
respecto de y es igual a 6 cuadrada + 3
ahora esta primitiva de de dh prima pues
simplemente es 2 y al cubo más 3 verdad
simplemente integrando y podríamos poner
una constante más pero ya vimos en otros
vídeos que no tenemos que preocuparnos
demasiado por eso así que cuál es
nuestra función si lo voy a escribir con
un nuevo color nuestra función si de xy
es una función que depende de xy de g
y esto será igual a x al cubo - x
cuadrada x + + 2 x más nuestra función h
que en este caso ya vimos que es
2 y al cubo más 3
y luego podríamos agregar una constante
más pero ya vimos que no importa mucho
realmente ahora lo que quiero hacer
ahora es un poco distinto quiero volver
a la intuición porque no quiero que esto
sea completamente mecánico así que
permítanme mostrarles cómo es la
derivada decir respecto de x incluso aún
si no su suite si no saben qué es lo que
pasa con la regla de la cadena de las
derivadas parciales como lo hemos visto
anteriormente
entonces si derivamos si respecto de x
ok utilizando únicamente habilidades de
diferenciación implícita pues tenemos la
derivada del primer término es 3x
cuadrada y luego la segunda pues
utilizamos la regla del producto verdad
entonces nos va a quedar aquí menos
un signo menos y luego la derivada de la
primera es 12 x por g y luego hay que
sumar x cuadrada por la derivada de la
segunda función que en este caso pues
simplemente será ye prima ok
justamente verdad entonces sólo estamos
derivando respecto de x y es una función
de x ok muy bien entonces el siguiente
término pues su deriva de fácil es
simplemente 2 y luego derivamos este
término respecto de x pues utilizamos la
derivación implícita verdad entonces nos
queda simplemente al derivar primero
respecto de y pues 6 cuadrada y luego
multiplicamos usando la regla de la
cadena por la derivada de la función ya
que es justamente de prima finalmente
vamos a derivar este último término y
nos queda 3
y al derivar respecto de x pues nos
queda la derivada de respecto x que
prima no entonces veamos si podemos
simplificar esto esto simplemente será
3x cuadrada menos dos equis y más dos
más dos que son justo estos términos que
estoy subrayando esos son los que
primero me tomé y ahora pues sólo
pongamos los demás términos ok esto será
de prima ok vamos a factorizar y prima
de los demás términos estamos y aquí
sería menos x cuadrada muy bien más 6
cuadrada
ok solo factor izamos de esos términos
más 3
esto es la derivada de nuestra app sí y
utilizando la derivación implícita pues
es lo que obtenemos y ahora hay que
observar qué es exactamente lo mismo que
nuestro problema original entonces lo
que obtenemos es que el problema
original era 3x cuadrada menos 2x más 2
ok
todo esto más
6 cuadrada - x cuadrada + 3 y todo esto
multiplicando allí prima y esto lo
igualamos a 0 que este era nuestro
problema original entonces observamos
que la derivada de pepsi con respecto a
x utilizando la derivación implícita es
esto así que esperemos que esto de más
intuición de como reescribir esta
ecuación porque entonces tendremos que
la derivada de pesic respecto de x
esto es igual a 0 porque esta es la
derivada de pge y con respecto de x que
es lo que escribí aquí ahora esto lo que
nos implica inmediatamente al tomar una
primitiva de ambos lados o la integral
como gustes llamarlo es que si de xy es
igual a una constante muy bien y sabemos
que si es por lo que acaba lo que
acabamos de ver en esta en esta línea de
acá arriba ok por lo tanto no tenemos
que hacerlo cada vez de hecho este paso
aquí esté aquí ya habríamos acabado
verdad
esto solo fue una prueba expedida
por algunas inquietudes acerca de que a
lo mejor estuviéramos haciendo esto muy
mecánico verdad así que hasta este punto
de arriba ya teníamos la solución yo
sólo quería mostrar en efecto
usando la derivación implícita que si se
cumple la condición que vimos en alguno
de los otros vídeos muy bien es decir en
el lado izquierdo de la ecuación
diferencial es justo la derivada de sí
respecto de x y lo igualamos a 0 pues
porque así estaba la ecuación
diferencial tomando la primitiva de
ambos lados tendremos que si es igual a
una constante y esta es la solución de
la ecuación diferencial o si deseas
escribirlos todo esto pues escribimos x
al cubo menos equis cuadrada más 12 x
más 2 y al cubo más 3 ya que este es
nuestra app si es igual a c que es la
solución implícitamente definida de la
ecuación diferencial muy bien entonces
de todas formas ya he agotado el tiempo
otra vez nos veremos en el siguiente
vídeo